et puis sachez que le responsable d'un
centre d'accueil pour réfugiés à pau a
été tué en fin de matinée l'attaqué a
été perpétrée au couteau par un
demandeur d'asile soudanais selon la
presse régionale la victime aurait elle
succombé après un coup porté à la gorge
l'auteur des faits a lui été interpellés
aux abords du lieu du drame grâce à
l'intervention rapide des pompiers et
des policiers le ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin et sur place et s'est
exprimé sur la situation les coupes
je voudrais surtout qu'on ne mélange pas
tout j'ai vu ici ou là quelques
réactions qui ne sont pas honneur à ceux
qui les ont faites
il est normal que la république applique
des règles quand on n'a plus vocation à
ses sauts territoire national on doit
repartir mais si tout à fait normal que
la république soit fidèle à la vocation
de la france d'accueillir des réfugiés
et de faire ce qui nous distingue
d'autres pays de le faire dans le calme
en donnant évidemment grâce à des
associations comme celle ci les moyens
aux réfugiés et aux demandeurs d'asile
de pouvoir en toute légitimité proposé
de rester ce territoire national est
normal que la l'administration en juge
donc je ne voudrais surtout pas qu en ce
jour de deuil qui est un jour de deuil
pour la ville de pau qu'un jour de deuil
pour le pour le pays pour la solidarité
le mélange dans tout